he doing anything but he's still gonna
wake up at four o'clock in the morning
four or five o'clock in the morning yeah
yeah well he doesn't get up that all
right
anymore he doesn't
um
okay how much do you guys think that
submission
costs so so i always hear that girls say
they need the right leader to be
feminine and submit to a guy like they
can't just be feminine and submit to
anyone
so at what income do you need a guy to
make to submit to him and trust his
judgment
and what do you and
like the reverse of this guy's point of
view do you think there should be a
minimum that girls should
submit to money-wise yeah
yeah
this is a question kevin samuels always
would ask you see the thing is
um speaking to the mac yeah the thing is
it depends in in where i'm at
so
am i earning more than you if i'm any
more than you if i if you're on
eighteen thousand a year and i'm 22 then
i'm the guy
you know
it i i don't think there's
i believe
that
it's it's in you or it's not
i'm either masculine or i'm not you're
either feminine or you're not
and if you are feminine the masculine
guys will find you and they will want
you
and
if you're
so i don't know i don't think it's a
money thing i think it's because for me
you could be a ceo and earn 250 and i
could earn 50. like you're not batting
me up like that i'm still gonna back you
up i'm still king of the castle
like and
i've i've seen that play out um it's
just you are who you are i can't become
submissive because you make more money
than me i'm not going to do it it's just
not it's just not in my dna so i i don't
know i don't
i don't think
money
i can't
quantify it so so devil's advocate here
right if i'm thinking i'm going to trust
the leadership of a guy that i'm dating
right and where i'm trusting him to make
the decision and obviously i have to vet
the guy yeah and so when they say that
submission costs i think a lot of times
like it's misconstrued where what women
need mean is we need a competent leader
right and it's not the bum right so at
some point at some point
it's hard to quantify because we can all
think of someone that maybe doesn't make
a lot of money but is very competent but
in general like there is a point where
there is a point yeah there is a point
but um
fro from a female's perspective
perspective i'd be looking for like is
he solid he's solid he does his own
thing
he don't ask nobody for nothing and he
just keeps it moving he's
self-sufficient
he's he's self-sufficient and
you know i've always been
self-sufficient so i don't need nothing
from you so you want to give me
something so as long as you're he's
holding a steady job
he does a job at the very least yeah and
yeah yeah and he doesn't have any debt
and he doesn't have any debt and he's
not making stupid decisions
okay
what about you and do you actually
question from a guys do you think if a
girl makes a lot of money and she's very
competent that she should be able to
submit to the average guy even if she's
more competent than him
i
i don't know
okay the thing is i don't think they
will
but i think
it depends on the guy like if if we meet
up and that's your that's how you do i'm
we're just gonna bump heads until one
submits and it ain't gonna be me so
if it's gonna be you then we can work
and sometimes it does take that for i'm
not gonna say all the time sometimes it
does take an alpha male to just like
make an alpha female know her place
sometimes
but yeah it's either in you or it's not
okay what do you think
um how much it would take to to submit
to a guy
um
kind of backing off from what he was
saying um
it'd have to just depend on how you are
like
you can be making millions of
pounds and whatnot and not be smart with
your money you know what i'm saying
um
but then again you can have
that much money to in it to a point
where even if you are stupid with your
money it's not really going to go
anywhere do you know what i'm saying so
um
i'd say
for me to be submissive
number one i have to respect you first
and foremost and respect like your
decisions and everything like that um
i don't know i i wouldn't say i'd put a
price on it
okay but respect i i'm not gonna lie and
say i wouldn't respect someone that's
making more than me
to an extent like if you're making more
than me have some sort of respect for
you but yeah you could be making more of
me and i've not be right with your money
but i'd have to respect you first and
foremost but i'd say
yeah i don't know
there's not really a prize
would you so it's like roughly just
being able to take care of himself have
his own place have like that sort of
thing yeah would you submit to a guy
that lives at his mom's house
is he paying the rent
yeah
um let's let's say no
no okay what about you
is that laptop is it permanent
um
no i'm saying what income so the first
question is what income
i i agree with her in terms of i
wouldn't put a price on it okay and i
feel like
like i said relationship is compromised
[Music]
relationship is compromised and
yeah to compromise there's a bit of
submission required on both parts that's
what i would say
oh actually in the the mom's house does
he have to be paying rent at the mom's
house for you to submit
let's say he's been living there for two
years
i think i would still submit but again
depends on the situation
like is he saving money to buy a house
versus is he just living there to live
there yeah yeah
yeah
and it depends on my own situation as
well
yeah
okay what about you i've never
dated anyone that's earned more than me
okay and i've always been submissive no
problem
okay but it's got to be
responsible it'll be a man yeah
yeah he's gonna be a man do you agree i
think a lot of guys can if
even if a guy makes less money if he's
overly masculine like i think he can get
like i think masculinity gives guys a
lot of points especially in like today's
day and age where the men i think
struggle with masculinity more than ever
yeah my mind's hot
he's very messy
i actually got um
got cussed
think something sarah said once and i
said that i was on holiday and i had on
the short shorts like short shorts and a
little top and i was at home and
somebody made a comment
a man made a comment towards the way i
looked i happened to mention it to my
man who was in england at the time
and he said what were you wearing he saw
us he goes but there's men around the
house you're too old to be wearing stuff
like that that's all right then i
changed and i got rid of it all and i
was told that
i was whipped and i was like my man's
telling me that i'm dressed in
appropriately so i've changed my clothes
well i supposed to listen to a woman but
they seem to think that because i was
earning more than him
but he's the head of the relationship so
you don't need no man girl that's what
they think
i don't need a man